Hello everybody, hope that you're good.
This a new Bitcoin update and it's going
to be an update based more on the
context, on what I'm seeing in, you
know, in high time frame and also a low
time frame opportunity that I'm looking
to trade. But, overall, I want to, you
know, talk more about high time frame
because
we're in a very delicate level in the in
the chart that could decide literally
between a bull or a bear market, so
we're going to be talking about it, but
overall, what I'm seeing here is that we
are above support.
All right, so I cannot be passing
pessimistic right here, okay? If we lose
support, then yeah, but at this
time, I'm also thinking that what is
happening now, I've been thinking that
this was a
a probable scenario a few weeks ago.
Then, I'm looking more for a
bounce than, you know, losing support
and continuing going lower. So, let's
get started.
Again, this is my opinion for you to
criticize, so I'll see you in the
comments, I guess, to hear your
opinions.
And overall, you could say that this is,
you know, some kind of a downtrend,
especially if you go into the 4-hour
time frame, for example. You can see
that we keep making, you know, lower
highs and lower lows. Yes, that's a
valid area. Also, we could discuss that
this could be some kind of a range that
will be your range highs, test as
resistance twice. Your range lows could
be somewhere around the 100% of this
week. Right now, we could be, you know,
around the range lows, give or take.
But, overall, yeah, I'll buy you. In in
low time frame, this is a
downtrend, all right? Now, if we go
and this is to me the issue. If we go
into the daily time frame, I'm going to
start to see, you know, some signs that
we're above support and that we could
see a bounce, okay? The first thing is
the weekly 50-MA
that it is.
We are right above it. It's at 101,000.
Price is right above it. So,
the most likely scenario is that, you
know,
this could hold, but but I want to put
it with more confluences. Now, no
indicators, no drawings in the chart,
naked chart. The first thing that I see
is this week's to the downside, but
price is not progressing any lower. That
means that the market maker might be
building longs
at the lowest possible
zones of these candles, which are these
weeks.
All right? So, so far,
at the moment, I can see that there is
some kind of interest in holding price
above that level, which is also the
weekly 50-MA.
All right?
Now,
potentially, you know, we could form
another week over there, but at the
level that I want you to keep in mind
is and this is my invalidation, by the
way, is if you take this low,
all right?
It's possible
that we could see even a sweep of these
lows, okay? Before price, you know,
bounces. Finding acceptance below this
week over here, below 92,200
would open the door
to a bearish scenario, all right?
That's what I'm seeing at the moment,
so, you know, you have weeks to the
downside, but price is not progressing
any further. You are above the weekly
50-MA support.
Now, it's possible that price does, you
know, a deviation, a sweep of these
lows, but if it does
something like this instead,
all right? It might drop and then it
starts, you know, to consolidate, you
know, for a few
say, couple of days, 3 days below this
area, then, you know, be scared because
price could continue dropping lower
towards low 90s, all right? So, that is
the part that I would
um make me
change my my mind and stop favoring
longs for shorts, all right? So, so far,
I favor longs. Now, another confluence
that, you know, if I take this
this level here,
you can see that it's a very strong
support. Okay? You can see how many
times price reacted at that level, okay?
Countless of times, really.
Being the last time, also here. The
weeks that we are seeing right now, all
right? So,
again,
for context, the daily time frame and
the weekly time frame is
fine. The structure is intact. However,
you know, we're at a very delicate level
where everything could change very
quickly, so
be open-minded. Now, the way that I'm
trading this
is, you know, let me let me take this
here,
is opening longs, for example, this area
here. I know, it seems like it just took
it perfect.
This area here.
I've been talking about this area on X
for a few days. As you can see, it's an
an area where you could imagine there
are a lot of stop losses
right in this area, okay? So, it's very
likely that price sweep these lows.
There you go.
Done, all right? That area had to get
taken out.
When I when price was here, we knew that
it was very likely that price dropped
and take these lows, all right?
So,
at least we got that area taken.
However, price could continue
dropping, okay? To the lows
of
Let me take here,
daily time frame,
to the lows of June,
98,200. That's to me
the lowest it can possibly go
in a bullish scenario. Now, based on
this, let's talk about opportunities
that I see to trade. In to me, in
Bitcoin, there are only two
ideas that I have, two setups, okay? Two
areas of interest. The first area of
interest is
what we've just seen right now, okay?
Taking these lows. Now, that is
basically a liquidity grab and now price
can continue going higher, all right?
That is the first level of interest. We
just hit it now. Price could go up from
here. It's possible. It's a fact, it's
possible. Now, the second idea
is taking out these lows,
all right?
Take out these lows,
find acceptance above it again very
quickly,
okay?
Go back above the weekly 50-MA
and then price could continue going
higher, all right? Just some kind of
liquidity grab around the weekly 50-MA,
which is something that we see often, so
that is the the the two areas, in my
opinion, that price could react from to
the upside.
And I'm
I'm playing that accordingly now.
Solana is, for example,
a coin that I'm seeing that, if you
know, if Bitcoin decides to go up from
here without taking these lows from
June, then I think that Solana is one
that, you know,
the chart is looking pretty good.
So,
excuse these drawings.
They are kind of old.
Um Solana is one that, you know, it has
here
some kind of, you know, range that
should be your range highs.
These could be your range lows, okay?
You can see this kind of price action.
Maybe it go a bit lower, okay? And then
price could go, you know, to take, for
example, this liquidity pool at 186.
Okay? So, Solana is one of the coins
that I would be betting now
for it to go up if Bitcoin goes up after
taking these these stop losses, okay?
However, if Bitcoin decides to go to
98,200
and take the the lows from June, then,
you know, you have to start to look for
a new area of Solana to to bounce from.
Um that could be somewhere around 136,
137, perhaps, okay? From what I'm
seeing, I can see some support at 137.
I think that will be the area that I
will be looking to
to engage again in longs, all right? So,
that's pretty much what I'm seeing right
now.
Uh keep an eye on Bitcoin, which also,
you know, it retrace the CME gap, as
it's been doing before. You can see,
we've marked these ones from previous
weeks and they get
filled straight away, all right? The
week after, usually. That's what
happened. It's very common, so right
now, keep an eye on Bitcoin, see if
there is a reaction from here
after taking those stop losses
or if it's going to go and take the lows
from June, okay? 98,200.
So, those are the two levels for
Bitcoin. I'm still favoring longs
until proven otherwise.
And that would be acceptance below
June's lows, okay? So, that's pretty
much everything, guys. Thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon.